you own a holdco i think gridley
enterprise is the name of it within it
you have a bunch of different things so
you own stuff as funky as like a
fireworks company called alamo fireworks
you own like a software
roll-up called dura software
um
you have like a coffee chain i think is
that right you have your a drive-through
coffee chain that's got like three or
four locations or something like that
um and then you incubate a couple a
couple projects one of one of which i
used actually recently
[Music]
uh michael what up dog shawn where are
you you're in tahoe i'm in lake tahoe
yeah
how is it
it's amazing yeah this place is great
is it just a getaway from crypto
no it was a father's day trip so
uh you know came out here
with my wife's family and uh
yeah it's been cool just been like at
the lake in the pool all that good stuff
that's awesome who who so you sean you
want to introduce this guy yeah okay
great so we got michael gerdley is that
the way you say it
yep
yeah michael's here i've been following
you on twitter for a while
and uh and i think you almost want you
almost bought our nft for the five
minutes of fame but uh you got outbid at
the last minute is that right
yes
yeah i had a whole plan about it i was
actually going to shard it and then try
to make profit from it and sell it in 15
second increments but
some really rich crypto person came in
and swooped it out from under me
sorry sam loves i had a huge plan i had
a huge plan
[Laughter]
uh and and but you but it worked anyways
you got on the pod anyways without it
because
uh you're a pretty interesting dude i've
been following you on twitter
mostly because you tweet about chili's a
lot and i'm a big chili's guy huge
chili's fan um
but you also
you kind of fit into this sort of like
andrew wilkins bucket which is like you
run a hold co and you run like a pretty
big hold co
and so let's just give people kind of
like your your rundown here's what i
know about you um
you own a holdco i think gridley
enterprise is the name of it within it
you have a bunch of different things so
you own stuff as funky as like a
fireworks company called alamo fireworks
you own like a software
roll-up called dura software
um
you have like a coffee chain i think is
that right you have your a drive-through
coffee chain that's got like three or
four locations or something like that
um and then you incubate couple a couple
projects one of one of which i used
actually recently called near which is
like a way easy way to hire people in in
latin america and i found this awesome
dude you know not a plug for near
necessarily but it did work it did work
exactly as intended i found this awesome
operations guy for my ecommerce business
there nico um
so so yeah so that's what you do
and um i don't know sam where do you
want to start we could we can go into
into kind of high level or we could dive
into any of the details where do you
want to start he put together this
really good document that explains all
the different businesses but to
summarize it looks like it's like eight
or nine or ten of them and so so i
understand the size it's over 100
million in revenue right and over 750
employees for all eight or ten of these
yes whenever i hear people be like okay
yeah my my kind of the accumulation of
the businesses that i own some
percentage ownership stake in is worth
over 100 million dollars or like a real
estate guy will be like you know i have
a billion dollar real estate portfolio
in my head and i'm sure there's a bunch
of listeners who are like this too
they're like so what does that mean are
you like are you are you super loaded is
this a like how do i think about that
number right because like you know if i
get a salary that's the money i keep if
i run a business and i say top line
revenue that's not the money i get to
keep so when you own a you own 100 of
your hold co and your holdco owns
businesses that add up to over 100
million in revenue
does that mean you're just big ball of
shot calling are you paying yourself
like 10 million dollars a year or more
out of out of the profits of these
businesses or what does that really mean
yeah
well i mean
part of the way i've set up the
structure is like i wanted to be very
flexible in terms of strategy so there's
some stuff in here that's just like
compounders like
um dura for example like we want to be
the next constellation software someday
so like i don't that's just compounding
the money i put into that and the effort
and time and i put into it like i don't
i don't get cash flow from that stuff
but that's by design like i'm just a
long-term player and a long-term person
on all this stuff you know the things we
went through just kind of the 10 big
holdings that i have those are all
things that i have
50 60 30 40 percent of companies so it's
not like i i told him with you like i've
i you know i felt stressed being like
okay well i don't want to be the guy
coming in and bullshitting about a bunch
of numbers but also like i'm from texas
and like like i have a hard time like
bragging and being like well okay here's
some here's what my net worth is and
here's how much money i make and all
that kind of stuff so i'm trying to
balance it out to where we can actually
get there without getting past my
comfort zone how do we let's let's not
balance that out let's just go to the
other end and make it incredibly
uncomfortable
tell me
how
your net worth your checking account
number and what it felt like when you
lost your virginity you could pick one
go now
uh really drunk
four
and uh yeah
yeah let's let's really get into it it's
like oh you don't want to reveal you
don't want to reveal your penis size
that's fine just tell me about your net
worth then we'll settle for that
but it's just there's like a mental
model for these businesses right like
some businesses like you call it a
compounder right it's like
uh if you go into a business like this
you're gonna put up it only takes x
dollars to start
and then it takes y years to kind of get
to some good outcome like like i'll just
give you like a venture startup right
like i come from the silicon valley
venture world silicon valley venture
world is you put zero dollars of your
own money up but you're gonna raise
likely somewhere between three and 300
million from venture capitalists over
time
uh you shouldn't expect to see any big
money until you exit which is on average
seven to ten years and so like that's
the profile of that versus my e-commerce
business took i don't know i put in 600k
to start it uh like that was my first
kind of year uh commitment that i had to
put in
um but we can take quarterly profits now
you know a year or two we could take
quarterly profits if we wanted to we
decided to roll that into growth but we
think that by three or three or four we
should be seeing pretty healthy you know
quarterly profits that will pay for
a sweet lifestyle right so that's like
just to paint a picture of what type of
business you're getting into most people
don't know how the holdco business works
so give me those sorts of like what does
it take to start how long do you have to
wait to get a payday how big are those
paid you know are you playing a software
game like a vc software game you can
make a billion dollars e-commerce
unlikely to happen but you can pretty
safely make tens of millions of dollars
if you do it right yeah well i mean i
think
my theory on stuff is it's been
incredibly difficult to find good
opportunities over the past five years
so i've structured stuff that i want to
be able to do
any opportunity that comes through the
door right and so like so the danger is
say for example
i run across a fun idea to work on that
you know maybe is in the roll-up space
well like like that's going to require
outside capital right dura required
outside capital my partner and i who
started the business he's former head of
support for rackspace he's the ceo of
the business now we put up our own money
to do the first acquisition and then we
started when we ran out of money right
after a couple million dollars um we had
to go out and raise money and so that's
playing that kind of vc compounding game
that i talked about you know other stuff
like the coding bootcamp that we start
like that pays me money every month it's
it's similar to what you're talking
about um so
you know those the thing i like about
those kind of cash flowy llc's and stuff
like that is like
you know the upside isn't as good like
you can't have a billion dollar exit in
that stuff 20 years from now but you can
start cash flowing really quickly um so
i like to have a blend of all those
things because you can you can't live on
appreciation how much how much profit
does the 100 million make or i think you
said over 100 million but let's just say
it's 100 million how much profit does it
actually make and let's say that you own
30 of one company that makes
10 million in profit do do you say like
all right we're gonna take of that 10
million we're gonna uh take out three
million in profit we own thirty percent
we get one million yeah
well i
typically the stuff in a portfolio for
small businesses like this
is going to end up run 15 to 20 percent
you know ebit emergence
so then you do a calculus and say okay
well based on that like free cash flow
potential margins like okay you got to
pay off debt service and all that kind
of stuff if you have it and then is it
better if you take the money out or
should you reinvest it inside the
business
and by and large most of these things
are reinvesting because i don't have
better places to put the money than
reinvesting in assets and new
acquisitions and all that kind of stuff
which business is the best cash cow is
it like you know that the fireworks
company where it's like well yeah open
like three months a year and it just
prints ca it prints profits for three
months and then we like don't have to
think about it for the other nine like
yeah that's true i'm just saying that
out loud which business is the best one
and why is it fireworks
dude fireworks here's why i love
fireworks it was the first business that
started my whole platform and i was the
ceo of it and it is the hardest business
in the world to run like it the cash
flow sucks like we we aren't even open
yet for fourth of july we open in two
more days and we've been spending money
to get ready for it all the way through
through uh since january the second
and you have to predict what's going to
happen six to twelve months ahead of
time and then you have to put up all the
cash for it buy all the fireworks get
all the locations out of we have 200
locations across the state of texas and
then open them all up uh and then we
really don't break even until about
seven or eight pm on the night of the
4th of july so it is when i ran that
business that was where i cut my teeth
as a ceo like it was the hardest
business to run to where i went to these
other businesses and people would like
pay you before you delivered the service
or like like when you started the coding
bootcamp was the second business and i
was like you mean they pay us before we
teach them the classes like this is
amazing i thought it was the greatest
thing ever so every other business feels
like how much revenue does the fire one
do fireworks
uh it's multiple tens of millions yeah
no [__] that makes let's say 20 30 40
million dollars selling fireworks for
two weeks uh we do it twice a year uh
fourth for the fourth of july and then
we do it again for new year's in texas
it's warm enough that actually new
year's is more pleasant than any place
else golly that's amazing and that's
good and that's quite profitable if you
do well for the
like the remaining like three hours and
then three hours you make all your
profits
all your profit because everybody shows
up at the last minute that's the other
part i didn't tell you yeah nobody buys
anything until the last day because
consumers have this habit of not doing
things ahead of time so that that
business is actually kind of an ugly
business then um because it's like you
have to predict things and i don't know
the world is very unpredictable the last
few years
so you have to predict demand you have
to operate really well in a very tight
time crunch like all your demand gets
squeezed into this tiny pipe um you're
putting up all the cash up front so
you're taking some some risk there
did you you're a clever guy did you come
up with any clever operating hacks to
like make that business suck less that
other firework people don't really do uh
yes we have a bunch of those i didn't
come up with any of them uh the thing i
realized and this was about 14 15 years
ago i actually really suck at
optimizations like i want to live at
like 80 000 feet with like big ideas and
strategy and doing what we're doing
right here right like i want to live in
an idea space and what i realized about
six years into running that business was
i am precisely the wrong person to run
this business because what you're
talking about is just like game of
inches where you have to be like
optimizing stuff all the time and like i
find that incredibly boring like that is
the mo like that and accounting and hr
are like the three most boring things
you'd ask me to do in my life and what
we've done is a ton of those kind of
optimizations like that business has
exploded in the past five years no pun
intended
through just getting the right people on
the field and it means me not doing it
because absolutely the wrong perfect
wrong person to run that business
but we do a bunch of different stuff
like we brought
digital point of sale to that business
it used to be handwritten for a long
number of years um so some pretty basic
stuff that you're like really it took
that long but yeah we we've done all
that kind of stuff but the
it's the royal we it's not me
how much money did you you said you
started this thing with two million
dollars of you and your partner's money
and then is the rest like a fun that you
raised
so um so dura was something i started we
started with our own money uh the
fireworks business i got that the
old-fashioned way i it's a family
business i inherited it
so that's why you're like how this kind
of with the fireworks business i i was
told i have a fireworks business now and
it's great
what about the other things did you have
to it's like is is each one like its own
you raise money for each one if you need
to raise money or you just use your own
money yep just uh if if i need to
syndicate the deal i syndicate the deal
with other people
um you know what i've learned and i only
do is i hate raising money for stuff
unless i'm putting my own money in it so
i'll put a substantial amount of my net
worth and new stuff and then when i go
out to raise money i feel like not yucky
otherwise i feel yucky but yeah which of
the business okay so we thought maybe
the fireworks business is the best one
it turns out that's kind of a
pretty pretty gnarly business what which
of your businesses would you say is like
the most
in the cash flow category like it's just
so beautiful because it works it's just
it just worked right away didn't take a
ton of money it's uh you know it's
profitable it's not like this brutal
business to operate which which one do
you like the best yeah uh the coding
bootcamp is the best one it's all
services low capex
um and then i mean the thing i like the
most about it like
it actually like helps people like it
changes their lives and that's not
[__] by the way like you'll notice a
theme like on all this stuff i really
like enjoy helping people and it it's a
life transformation thing when people go
through that and get a better job
clearly you've never had a bottle rocket
fight man
because those are pretty amazing too
uh that is that is uh low eight figures
that's amazing
and very profitable uh that runs kind of
consistent with what we're talking about
that 15 to 20 even emergence and and so
um so you got a bunch of these so um
i like your twitter because um
you talk about a bunch of things that i
think most people aren't talking about
my feed is very like i don't know my
twitter feed is just like the same
crypto people the same silicon valley
people and then there's like five people
that are like just you know different
and i think you're friends with all of
them like that guy molson i think is
like a total nut i find him his feed to
be hilarious uh you're kind of a nut
you're hilarious uh there's this guy jay
vasileva i don't know how to say his
last name exactly long indian last name
he's super smart and like you know
people just don't follow you guys in the
same like to the same level as i think
you should um like i'll make a list of
these people i'll tweet it out because i
think you guys are all way more
entertaining on twitter than most um but
i want to read you a couple of tweets
and i want you to just kind of riff on
like kind of explain it
but riff on what you what you mean there
like what was the kind of the golden
thing there so
um you had one about going to
touristy places but doing non-touristy
things you were tweeting out like you
were in china
you're tweeting out like what a
a
paper recycling mill
like what is waste paper from the us
where does it go once we like where does
the waste paper go and you like found
where it goes in china it was this
gnarly
factory
and so like i don't know if you could
talk about that or just this idea of
going
going on vacation or going to a touristy
place but then hitting the non-touristy
parts of that country uh talk a little
about that yeah well that was a i mean
that was a business trip like i was
there
training the team and helping them go
learn how to buy fireworks um and like
we were just like driving down the road
and like
literally so the process of going to buy
fireworks uh is there is like a silicon
valley of fireworks and it's in china
and it's about a two-hour flight from
hong kong in the southeast of china and
you go to this place and like it's the
same thing every day you go the chinese
take you to a fancy dinner and there's
always the same restaurant the same food
and then they take you to a factory and
then they shoot you some fireworks and
hopefully you buy them and that happens
like for six days in a row and then and
you have to drink a bunch of nasty bijou
they just they have like budweiser
chinese budweiser
they serve you and it's pretty fun
yeah it's pretty fun um but yeah after
like the fourth year of doing that like
i was there with with the team and i was
we were like driving along and i was
just so sick of going to yet another
fireworks factory because they all look
the same it's just like
the same little old ladies like doing
the same thing and all the fireworks
workers by the way are like 70 years old
they can't hire young people to work in
fireworks factories this is crazy and i
was like what is that over there and uh
and they're like oh that's the box
factory and i was like a box factory
let's go over there and so they pull
over to the side of the road the driver
goes in
and the chinese seller to us like takes
us in for a tour of this box factory and
for me it was just like an opportunity
to kind of push a little bit and like
really get underneath and understand
like how a culture like lives and really
functions and like he told us like look
they're they're having problem making
boxes now because they can't put the
waste water directly in the river
anymore i was like oh this is why things
are so cheap in china um but yeah that's
it like just you just kind of start
wandering and then magic happens so that
was one of those what type of trip was
that where you uh bring a bunch of texas
firework workers to china and like
yeah i just imagine like just like what
the [__] is this soy sauce [__] you know
what i mean just like imagine that
conversation and uh that was you must
have had a blast hanging out with a
bunch of uh
texas firework guys and a bunch of
chinese fireworks guys you guys that we
really got brought together there on
that one
our love of blown [__] up
yeah well i mean i'm somewhat worldly
the guy the guy that we took on the trip
actually the ceo for the business is a
former
uh a former senior military officer
who's romanian and lives here in san
antonio now used to work for aldi and
they didn't know what to make of him
like they were just totally confused why
we had a romanian with us like going
through rural china so it's pretty good
times
have you had any of these other like
have you intentionally gone and sort of
gone off the beaten path to like because
i feel like what you're when i look at
your your twitter feed you've sort of
accumulated a bunch of random disparate
business knowledge and a lot of this
comes from like oh you see a guy selling
something on the street you're like hey
so what is this where does this come
from how do you do this right that sort
of thing can you tell any other stories
of you know sort of like intentionally
stumbling into interesting things
because i think more people should do
that um
and i want to kind of like you know
hear some of those stories hmm it's a
really good question i need to think of
a good hat you think of a good answer
i'm glad we're i'm glad this is being
edited
um
when have i done that the most
yeah we went down one one time we went
down this is super interesting
um you know our business dura has some
employees in medellin in colombia you
know where bob escobar is from so we
went down there to just kind of like
start wandering around and like meet our
employees and like understand should we
outsource more here um
and we just started like going around
with a guide and just like asking people
questions like what do you think of
americans what is it like here and like
you just start to see random stuff um i
mean the reason i started the coffee
business by the way is like i was riding
my bike around arkansas and i'm like
just riding outside the walmart
headquarters because like i'm a business
nerd and staring at the walmart
headquarters and uh like there's this
like drive-through coffee shop there and
it was coveted and i was bored and i
just sat there for an hour and these
guys were just printing money and i came
home and i called my buddy who i'd
wanted to work with for years and i was
just like hey we should start a coffee
business and he said why and i sent him
the pictures i was like look at all
these people they're just like printing
money um so it's just kind of this idea
of just like for me like
like the way i build ventures and the
way i find them is just kind of by like
stumbling around like an idiot and then
like
you end up in front of the walmart
headquarters and watch some guys sell on
millions of dollars worth of coffee um
so yeah that's another story
and does uh you went to the berkshire
hathaway uh like summit which i think is
kind of like a pilgrimage
for like business people slash
entrepreneurs it's like you got to go
visit the mecca and like you see the old
kind of religious you know leader you
know
the 90 year old guru sitting there and
uh is it worth it should i go uh you
definitely gotta go at least once i mean
it was like so i'm 47 so like i always
regretted i didn't see jared garcia
before he died and uh like that was the
way i felt about seeing charlie and
warren and and you know it's like one of
those things where i was kind of happy
to be there because it felt like a
once-in-a-lifetime thing and the people
watching is amazing like it's like
it's like the combination of like
cash like investing and like a nascar
race like it's perfect
um so i just had so much fun doing it
but it's also kind of you know i feel
like going at this point like charlie
and warren are getting up there like
they're 92 and 98 like
the morning you know warren spent a lot
of time just kind of trying to find his
words and then he got into a rhythm and
it was like he was his old self again it
was pretty awesome but i mean i think if
you're a capitalist you got to go once
you just gotta go once because you're
just like
it's just such it's just such an insane
experience seeing these people so
devoted to the company dropping 250 on a
pair of roper boots or justin boots and
then walking over and drooling over like
how they can buy like a sunbeam boat
like it's just like
just the coolest thing so you gotta go
at least once
sam have you been
no uh i was invited to go i think you
and i were invited with sieva and suli
and i didn't go is it i guess i i guess
i would go just to see it
dude those guys are old aren't they like
isn't charlie munger like 93
oh my god yeah
i got a connector it would have to be
that
yeah i guess next year would have to be
like
the last one maybe
you gotta go just to watch him
and see how much peanut brittle he eats
in a four-hour setting like it was
unreal the guy ate like four pounds of
peanut butter and when i like
live-tweeted the thing like it was like
i can't believe he's still eating this
much peterborough i'm 47 there's no way
i could do that he was just sitting
there pounding it the whole time dude
that peanut butter from seas is fire i
feel that it is pretty amazing these
guys have like they have the most
success and they do the opposite of what
every like you know success coach and
like motivational entrepreneur
you know tells you to do it's like you
know they're like you know
it's like if you would go on instagram
it's like oh i need to you know wake up
at 5 00 a.m i need to you know meditate
i need to do my ice plunge then i need
to do my crossfit workout then i need to
like you know do my daily gratitude
journal then i need to do my like hyper
focus chamber where i go and i figure
out my priorities for the day then i
need to like speed read and
listen to my podcast on 2x speed and
these guys are basically like
you know they somehow made it they
became the richest people in the world
lived until they you know until they're
about 100 years old and they wake up
every day they eat mcdonald's breakfast
eat a bunch of m m's and diet cokes and
then they read and play bridge all day
and like go for walks and uh you know
that's where they get their
their ideas from
and so you know i think there's
something to what they're doing i think
it's a
you know i think they're still alive
because they're low stress despite what
they eat uh and i think they're they're
smart thinkers because they don't
overload their brain with information
like uh i'm guilty of and i think a
bunch of people are when you when you're
hooked into social media you're just
constantly consuming info
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago i totally missed
hubspot grow better
one of your of the things in your uh the
the things in your portfolio which
company besides the um
besides the the boot camp are you like
this is just the greatest thing ever i'm
so happy we own this
uh i more people should know how easy or
not easy but how straightforward this
business on it feels like i'm winning an
easy mode
yeah well i think
the near business so it's higher with
near.com
so it actually this is a this is the
this is the apex of what i want for
gridley existence to be which is i want
i've gone from starting businesses
myself and working in them then starting
businesses and having other people work
in them and this is one that has started
basically with me doing no work but i
have substantial amount on the cap table
like it's the apex of girdly automation
like i'm always scaling stuff so then
your business like we looked up and like
like i i'm in a ceo peer group and like
none of my peers could like hire people
like it was the past couple years it was
just such a mess
and then i'd ask them well have you
considered hiring overseas
and they're like i don't know how to do
that how would i do that so we
we basically i took one of my associates
and i said hey we should go build in
this direction there's this huge wave
and here's this problem let's go try
some stuff and see what happens
and that business i like so much just
because everything seems like it's on
easy mode because everybody's offshoring
like everybody wants to do this
it was that way when the economy was
going well now it's even more so when
the economy is going poorly
and i've hired personally of my
associates i have three of the six that
work
work overseas i've never met him in
person it's like the best
and you partnered with someone to make
this according to the about page right
yeah so um hayden is started as an
associate of mine so i hire these people
i call them associates and it's
basically an entrepreneur in training
program so i like mentor them through i
pay them a salary um and then i help
them like
get out of the like 12 bad ideas that
every entrepreneur has to get when
they're 27 years old i help them like
think through all those and then we work
on a good idea together and then at the
end of it they can either start a
company with me or they can go take a
job or whatever and so hayden and franco
were two of the guys in that program and
like i'm on the cap table with them like
i put up the money and have been guiding
them through it but they've done all the
work
when you're hiring ceos how much equity
do you give them and how much uh how
much do you pay them and how do you
incentivize them to want to stay with
you for a long time
yeah so totally depends upon the
situation um you know obviously if a
business is much more established
or demands somebody who's like much more
like um
like mature um that that makes a
situation where oftentimes you have to
come up with more
my best situations are when i can
partner with somebody so all this stuff
i'm in while i have significant stakes
in it i have other people on the cap
tables like that's one of my like i feel
like superpowers like i can just like
maintain partnerships like i have a 100
success rate on partnerships with people
so the absolute best way is if i can get
somebody like paul at dura is to be like
a co-founder and the absolute best way
of that is if they're a co-founder and
they put money in it like me and then
they make that their job like that's the
absolute best skin in the game kind of
outcome but you know you can have
anywhere from a 27 year old who will
make 60 to 80k a year plus benefits
to some of these people who are much
more senior like our coffee
our coffee person you know he worked at
25 years at circle k and he's running
he's running that business
he obviously needs to make much more
money than that
and then the equity really depends
totally depends on the opportunity it
depends on how much skin in the game
they want to have
what level of commitment they have and
how early they're coming in the venture
but it could be anywhere from 40 to 20
to 5
and why does let's say for dura uh why
does your partner want to give you
what let's call it let's pretend you
have 30 i don't know what you have maybe
it's 50 maybe it's a little less
let's just say 30 what does he want to
have give you 30
and he's a day to day in it but you're
not right uh so how do you think about
that like value exchange
um
when you're not going to be the
operating person and then they are
yeah well i mean
so you're asking that question from the
same lens i have which is like being an
operator isn't our dream most people
their their dream is to be an operator
they're excited when we're able to work
together and create an opportunity for
them to be their best self right and
that's what i see kind of as that
benefit and so and and so i think a
situation like that where like you know
oftentimes i'm part of the very early
figuring out what the idea is going to
be
i'm putting up a substantial amount of
money i put up more money than than say
the other partners did
we did some debt to do the first deal
like i personally guaranteed it
and then the last thing is like like
great teams they have these
complimentary things like how much money
would you use to fund a new business so
that one was like a couple million and
then some of these are like 50 to 100.
wow okay so that's why you do put up a
lot of money
yeah so
yeah skin in the game matters um then
that also helps me not to try to do too
many things like i could just be like
okay like i'm putting real money in this
i better really believe in it
um but like like the last thing with
these operators is a lot of the things i
feel like i bring to the business where
it's like strategy insights like best
practices and connections like those are
things that they're happy to have
somebody along on the journey with them
who has the same level of commitment um
and wants to be a board member like i i
don't want their job and i'm not i
wouldn't be good at it so you know i
think that's that's the partnership i
end up having with these folks
sean have you heard of um this guy named
kevin ryan
only through you he's like a media right
is that
the same guy
yeah so michael have you heard of this
guy kevin ryan i'm googling him all
right so i think there mike there's
probably a billion kevin ryan so like
maybe a baseball that's like a baseball
player oh he's the ally
so
yeah so listen to this guy
so early in his career he worked like in
the newspaper business nothing
particularly exciting and then he worked
at this company called doubleclick and
he was like the 30th employee there and
then took over as ceo and then
doubleclick was sold for like a billion
or many billion and it eventually became
adsense for google so a pretty big thing
he told me that he had made like
um very low digit eight eight figures uh
he was like there's enough money that
like i'm set but uh like i still wanted
to like create stuff and so him and this
guy named dwight who i think he worked
with at doubleclick
they started alicorp and their whole
thing was we're gonna fund companies
with 200 to 300 000
and all the ideas are going to come from
us all the ideas are only going to be
back of the envelope math and we're
going to hire someone to get it off the
ground and we're gonna give it 300 000
and six months to prove if this is a
good idea or a bad idea and we're gonna
do it a bunch of times a few of their
successes that they've done this with
are
uh
mongo.mongodb which i don't know what
it's at now but in the range of like a
20 to 50 billion dollar uh market cap
publicly traded software business the
second one is business insider which
sold for 600 million i think but it's
like a big company now the third one is
guilt guilt group which was a clothing
company that was huge it didn't actually
work out but it was huge for a little
while and i think the fourth one there's
another oh the fourth one is zola you
guys know zola it's like where you go
for wedding registries i believe that's
a unicorn and there might actually be
two or three more of these companies
that ali corp has like uh founded and
basically he was like yeah so me and
dwight just sit around and we come up
with a cool idea like i go to a wedding
and i just ask people where they bought
all the gifts and like he's like i just
had this idea so i knew someone who
worked at guild group who mentioned she
liked this type of business i hollered
at her i go hey here's 300k if you can
get this going and you get a small
portion but we get most of it you want
to try it and that's how it worked it's
a he's pretty amazing
speechless
that's impressive
it's like yeah i was like yeah those
guys are really good there's
this like holdco model is it's like in
vogue right because it's sort of like to
me i i worked at a startup studio for a
while i think that was like the thing
for a period of time probably still is a
thing where yeah you build one company
you run it for a while you sell it great
now you got cash you still want to do
more entrepreneurial things and so you
self-fund a studio where like we're
going to work on a bunch of ideas and
then you
try to find like new winners out of
those bunch of bunches of ideas and so
like you know i worked at out of one
that's how i got into tech
um you know mark pincus the guy who
created zynga then he created one the
guy who created uber he created one
kevin rose created one like it's just a
bunch of serial entrepreneurs who create
these and they've actually had a pretty
poor track record of success
and then we see that like the holdco
mafia is sort of the same where you get
you know
um guys like andrew wilkinson who's got
tiny and then you have
you know a bunch of other people who are
doing their own holdco
versions of that whether they buy boring
businesses they buy sweaty businesses
they buy software businesses they buy
whatever um and you're kind of in that
boat you're in that boat too
uh what do you think is the
i guess like how do you think about that
you know in terms of like who do you
think should be the type of person who
who should do this and and what are some
of the misconceptions or like traps that
people fall into when they go down this
path because i'm sure you've seen a
bunch yeah well i mean i think there's
two there's two bad things going on with
hold codes right now i think there's a
whole group of people
that are doing them and they actually uh
think it's not that much work
like
i talked about i'm like so why are you
doing this they're like uh it seems
really easy i'm like this is really hard
and the reason number two that it's like
super hard is because this is exactly
the opposite of operations like the
everything that you do and all the
habits and skills that you learn when
you are a ceo running a business which
is where most these people are coming
from or your senior exec in a company
like everything you do in a hold code is
exactly the opposite like like when
there's a problem you don't rush in and
fix it for your company you actually say
man that really sucks what are you gonna
do about that two entirely different
things in terms of the way you approach
it so
i mean it'll be interesting to see what
happens with all these people who think
hold codes are really hot um as i talk
to most of them i don't think as many of
them are wired to be holdco people as
they really think they are like the me's
the xavier hulkinsons like like we're
odd like we're different people and
there's a reason for that that we're not
operators and so it'll be it'll be
interesting to see what happens um with
some of these people what's so hard
about it you know i think it goes
against people's nature right so like
like take me for example like i love to
live in this idea space right and i'm i
have like a relatively crappy memory
which is like why i have to write stuff
down like crazy um
but that's different for other people
like a lot of the people that i partner
with as operators they look at like what
i do as
insanity because they just couldn't
imagine letting go of the vine of these
particular things going on and so you
know it goes against this human nature
where a lot of times like for example
those people like there's this problem
going on in the business they want to
sprint to that problem right and they
can't imagine even stepping away from it
so it just goes against in my opinion
who you are as a person and makes it
almost incredibly difficult or
impossible for them these people yeah
you say that but at the same time i'm
like oh
everybody i know is like oh i like to
operate at a high level you know the 10
000 foot view and i'm an ideas guy i
don't know anyone that doesn't think
they're an ids guy maybe i just run in
the wrong circles but you know i don't
know a lot of people who are like you
know what i like to grind the operator
likes to go grind the day-to-day
optimizations versus
i like to be the idea guy who helps just
get it started and somebody else goes
and does all the hard work you know that
seems like
seems like there's a ratio of 100 idea
guys to every one guy who just truly
loves executing
you ever heard of excel dog that's my
jam
oh no no you
i lived in the silicon valley bubble too
like i was i fit right in i was great
there and then i came back here to the
hinterlands of san antonio and like i
started to see these people and like
i've got buddies who for example are
senior executives at the largest private
grocery chain in america heb have you
guys heard of this company
yeah i love heb it's like my favorite
grocery store it's insane
you should see how optimized those guys
are when they're running at three or
four percent even at margins and like
they think it's great tell me everything
about heb yeah uh what do you want to
know
like what what why what makes it so
great it all comes down to it all comes
down to the philosophy of the family
that owns it so you have charles butt
who is the majority owner and then his
his relatives are the other rest of the
owners and then they have a percentage
that's owned by the employees but it's
like 85 90 percent owned by but by these
guys um and so they'll just do crazy
stuff like when they heard um when they
heard that trader joe's was coming to
san antonio so he's located here
there's an anecdote that they just
packed up all the senior executives who
were in charge of product selection
location selection interior store
experience all that stuff they put them
on a private jet and they flew out to uh
to california and said don't come back
until you have the best of every single
one of their products because we need to
up our game
um there's another anecdote when walmart
came to san antonio that heb went and
lowered their profit targets because
they're just like we're not losing to
walmart that's just the way it's gonna
work and that all emanated from the
ownership right you didn't have this
like public stock people coming in and
saying like oh like think quarter by
quarter now you had these folks that
were thinking like we've been here for
70 years how are we going to be here for
another 70 years
and just go crush it and that goes all
the way down the culture
my buddy works there and he said it took
10 years um before people stopped
referring to him as the new guy
people just stay
yeah imagine that in silicon valley
of all the it sounds like to you that
like heb is almost like a dream business
or not a dream business but it's one
that like you look at and you're like
damn that is cool that is well run i
admire a few things about that what else
do what other companies do you admire
that most people don't maybe know about
or think about when it's like oh that's
actually really neat for these following
reasons
hmm really good question
what other businesses are super sexy
i feel like i've talked about sexy
but it's just like things where it's
like uh
man this is these guys got it made
they're it's hard work but it seems like
it's like pretty fun and i think that
what they're doing has a lot of soul and
they're doing it right
sam do you have one while he's thinking
yeah
uh i mean it does seem like it's a lot
of family guy stuff i would say um
do you guys do you guys know blah blah
uh black rifle coffee i've heard of them
but i don't know much about them i don't
drink
so i don't really drink too much of it i
drink the black stuff because the other
stuff has a lot of sugar they're
typically drink by like conservatives
like they've like do they've done like
they advertise on fox they've done like
a good job of uh like like this is made
in america it's all about freedom like
that whole thing which is well you know
whatever that's cool and but they're
like yeah let's sponsor rally
dirt rally race cars and i asked them i
was like why and they're like because
it's freaking awesome and like what's
the point of like having this company if
we can't do dope [__] like you know go
to a go to a rally car and give out our
coffee and or they'll do it with like
mountain biking races or they'll do it
with the like they make all this all
this cool content where they're just
like doing like the redneck version of
red bull stunts you know like uh
and i think that's awesome i love that
stuff i think that to me i imagine in
their heads they're like yeah
they're like we kind of care about
coffee but we really just care about
living a really cool amazing life and
letting people have fun and it just so
happens we're
we're selling a bunch of coffee that
allows us to to do that so that's a good
example of a business that i like and
they took it public and it's worth like
six or seven hundred million dollars so
it's like really successful
yeah they're located here in san antonio
have you seen it's it's super cool that
that business you think it's like a
coffee chain and it's actually just a
lifestyle brand it's all like you go
into the stores and there's like a
little coffee thing on the side and then
it's like all t-shirts and swag and it's
good-looking stuff like i'm not like
their demographic obviously but like
it's super fun to like go in there and
be like man these guys like i'd wear
that even though it doesn't represent me
i like them a lot sean do you have one
you know uh i do ha i do have a couple
um i like to i kind of admire like oh
[__] that's simple i like when it's
really simple and the person has cr has
like good life perspective so uh the guy
came on the podcast mike brown i met him
through you i've been about i went to
the hustle office and he was he was just
sitting there hanging out with you
and um
and you were like this guy's great you
know you know what's great about this
guy and i think
sam you probably know the story a little
better than i do but like
what they did was
they would go around to families in
texas
that that were like basically living on
a gold mine right it's like they were
living on some valuable deposit of you
know minerals or oil or whatever and
they would go knock on doors and they
would say hey you know you um
you're living on this land i'll like
we'll pay you for the land rights in
some way and they would go of those
assets and then they would never go do
the oil mining
or oil drilling themselves they would
then flip that to the oil company and
say hey look we got the title rights you
know clear and easy that are in the
earth and they were making a killing so
they were making you know
i don't know almost almost 100 million
dollars doing this is that right sam
yeah
i believe it was multiple eight figures
in profit a year
with like a team of like eight people
and they're like yeah so it was super
profitable super small super simple it's
like well basically we go knock on doors
we call people we explain what we're
doing and then we make them an offer
that they can't refuse like you know
they're not going to do anything sitting
on that land and so you know it to me
i'm like this is so simple you compete
with pretty much nobody um and then you
and then he was like i was like so you
bro it looks like your brother's working
the business like how's that working
with family you know some people say
different things about that and he was
like no it's awesome he's like i love my
brothers he's like you know uh
he's like my philosophy is you you know
you find the people that you love and
you do life with them
and he said that and it kind of changed
the way i i operated i was like oh yeah
who are the people i want to do life
with and like you know just kind of pick
the five people who are the most awesome
and then find excuses to do life with
them that sounded really simple like i
love sam i'm gonna do a podcast with sam
and it's like oh our buddy ramone's
awesome cool i'm gonna go on vacation
with ramone all right you know like you
want and like you know
hey this person's awesome why don't you
come work in one of my businesses right
rather than just go work in your own job
so i really liked i kind of admired that
philosophy and i admired just the like
sheer profits of what they were doing
and how simple it was and how it didn't
require
you know genius or like
honestly
i'm sure he felt like he was working
hard but it's not that hard like it's
not well he used to say he was like
everyone we hire we make him get into
cycling because we all we like going
bike riding for two hours in the middle
of the day he's like we all want to go
for we all want to go work out yeah yeah
so i kind of admire people who are the
anti-hard work crowd because i'm more of
that like you know can you work smarter
not harder and then can you even like
not feel like you're working can you
turn it into play by you know having
people who are awesome you know doing it
with you so i like that example the
other one is uh bill simmons who started
the ringer like i really don't think
media companies are very good business
and you know ironically just started a
media company but like
bill simmons is [__] awesome and he
kind of changed the game for
what he does like every sports
journalist did things one way he just
did it differently and built this he
built his following uh sort of
unapologetically and what did he do
differently
so he just like he wrote from the
perspective of a fan and that sounds
actually that's actually giving it too
much intellectual credit actually what
he did was he was like all right what
are the rules if you're a journalist
it's like you need to be objective he's
like how can i be objective dude i
follow sports because i love the boston
red sox i love the celtics i'm from
boston i grew up my dad used to take me
to the games he's like i'm going to
write as like
this
die hard fan and when my team wins i'm
going to be so happy when my team loses
i'm the sky is falling he's like that of
course was super relatable to a reader
because that's who your reader is it's
like a die hard sports fan so he like
didn't pretend to be objective that was
like the first part then he would be
like cool i'm also not just like this
flat thing that like i can only
like talk about sports so he's like oh
you know
i love the die hard trilogy so he'll
write a column that's like you know
if nba players were characters in die
hard here's who would be bruce willis
and die hard 2. and like you know he
would do these crossovers that didn't
nobody else really took those risks it
sounded crazy like
sam you know you and me both watch the
mtv's the challenge he's like a huge
challenge fan and he'll talk about it
he'll do a separate podcast about it
even though the audience is kind of
niche but it's so niche that when it
hits it hits in a very big way like it's
if it has a high like emotional score
when he does talk about something you
get you that you're in on the joke be
like the trade values he's one of your
heroes or the male bands one of your
business heroes and uh anyways then he
spun off did his he was doing podcasting
before it was popular before it was like
an obvious thing and so when he he
recently sold the whole company to
spotify for like 200 something million
but you know that i i kind of admired
that because it was like
he deserves that he was podcasting
before podcasting was a thing and so
yeah he now has the number one sports
podcast and he can cash out and
all along the way there was never really
any
plan you could draw up how that podcast
was gonna make the guy 200 million
dollars someday it was like that was an
unfathomable thing but he did it because
he again it's kind of like your black
rifle example it's like yeah i'm just
gonna do it because i think it's fun and
it's cool [__] and like
i i kind of believe in this magic this
philosophy that if you take a bunch of
cool [__] you put it in the in the hat
you kind of mix up the hat like
something really good comes of that and
you don't have to be able to draw it out
you know ahead of time so i kind of i
tend to love examples like that because
i want to live my life more like that
where i just do things without so much
of a
of a of a mind map of exactly how it's
all going to pay off
dude i love that i think um i saw this
amazing quote i'm trying to find it but
it was from kanye and he was like saying
i despise people who do things i can't
find the exact quote but he's like i
despise people who do stuff and they
don't want it to be dope he's like i
wanna if i'm gonna do a clothe if i want
to do a clothing company i'm making a
dope even if that means i lose money i'm
making it dope i'm making it awesome he
kept using the word dope and he's like
i'm just gonna do stuff because it's
amazing and yeah it'll probably make
money but for all the people out there
who just do stuff just to get the money
but they don't want to make it awesome
in the process i think that's really
weak and not cool and not difficult you
heard that dave chappelle's story he
tells on like some late night show about
kind of yeah tell it my life is yeah
yeah yeah i don't remember the exact day
he's like i was hanging out with kanye
and then kanye got a call who was it
somebody called him who was it
so it was uh it was uh kanye was
backstage with dave chappelle and jay-z
and kanye was just coming up and he was
playing a uh a jay-z song and kanye's
verse comes up and kanye's like the noob
in the room and he goes wait stop that
track rewind that and listen to that guy
and he like made him rewind and then um
he's like they're like dude what are you
doing man you're not like you're the big
shot here and then uh he gets a phone
call and he goes
oh hello
yeah
yeah that's fine but uh can i call you
back
uh yeah well i'm backstage watching
never seen before clips with dave
chappelle yeah because my life's dope
and i do dope [__] and then hangs up i
think that's
yeah exactly
i love that story that is the best and
also um like
that philosophy is actually kind of
amazing first of all to believe in your
own life being dope like how many people
think that their life is dope that they
are dope and they do dope [__] and
therefore they have a dope life like
most people don't give themselves that
credit
and you know they're kind of waiting for
dope stuff to happen for them to be able
to say that kanye's the opposite right
he's crazy in a bunch of ways but one of
the good ways he's crazy
is that he just declares my life is dope
and i do dope [__] and guess what you'll
kind of live up to that reputation if
you believe that about yourself right
like if you say you know um you know i
take chances you know i'm bold i take i
take bold risks well guess what you're
going to actually take the next bold
risk when the opportunity presents
itself because you've kind of hardwired
yourself to have that identity when we
were sam you'll like this
at bibo when um we hired this guy jason
hitchcock and jason was
jason's the best person you can hire
because he will believe in you and the
cause
150 like he'll believe in you and the
mission if you're like his boss and your
manager or whatever like more than you
believe in yourself and he'll believe
that the company's gonna work even more
than the ceo is gonna believe he's like
i call him a kool-aid drinker like he
drinks the kool-aid and he's not ashamed
to do it and so he because he's like an
amazing person to have at a startup when
there's a actually a lot of people have
a bunch of doubt and uncertainty in
their mind and so one day i was talking
to jason and we were like
um the hustle con was coming around
around the corner and i was like i think
i'd message you i was like i want to
talk at hustlecon and i think you were
kind of like yeah like yeah i don't know
we got a bunch of speakers already you
kind of blew it off you're like you know
we
no and uh and i was like all right fair
enough but i asked and i was like i was
like jason next year we're going to talk
at house of con i was like in fact
not just next year we're going to talk
about hussocon in fact everything we do
this year i want you to think about how
it's going to play at your hustle con
talk you're going to give when you're
going to give this talk about how we
grew from what zero to a million users
how we took over the game in our
industry like
i want you to not just wake up and be
like okay today i'm gonna send out a
bunch of emails it's like i want you to
think about how this could be part of
your talk like how i landed the big fish
through cold emails or how i you know
growth hacked my way to do x and we used
to talk about that literally on a weekly
basis like this is part of the hustle
contact it was just to hype ourselves up
to like
do the more dope version of the task we
were already gonna do because like
imagine you're gonna talk about this on
stage that means it must have turned out
pretty dope or you must have done a
pretty dope attempt in order to have
that mindset and i i'll st i still carry
that to this day of like that's a pretty
cool way to work
um here's the uh here's here's the quote
by the way so this is from kanye he said
for me dopeness is what i like most
people who want to make things as dope
as possible and by default make money
from it the thing that i like least are
people who want to make money from
things whether they're dope or not
especially make money from making things
the least dope as possible and i
i've read that quote and i was like
yeah we need to make the intro of the
podcast
find a clip of kanye saying that out
loud and let's make that the the opening
clip of the podcast um the other thing
we did by the way that's in this bucket
that i highly recommend people do
is it's tempting to say we should do
cool [__] yeah blah blah blah and then
like
fast forward a month everyone's feeling
tight about the budget or the deadlines
or the the goal numbers are not being
hit or whatever it's very what's the
first thing you cut is the stuff that
doesn't easily map to this quarter's
result
and
and so we separate we created a separate
do cool [__] budget it was 15 percent of
our total budget we put into a do-cool
ship bucket which the outcome of it had
to be where at uh there's a bib and then
i tried to do this also at twitch where
um which was like hey whatever the
number is that we have to spend 15
percent is gonna be on cool [__] that we
cannot like we it doesn't have a
measurable immediate payoff so that's
like the criteria you can't it can't be
used in this much like like making a
flamethrower like making a flamethrower
or like you know
i don't know if you saw this we did the
milk red rebrand or whatever and i paid
this guy to make this little video
that's like this mock apple commercial
and like it doesn't do anything it's not
gonna drive subscribers it's not gonna
like make revenue
uh it's i mean in many ways it is
arguably a waste of time and money to
just like pay the guy to do that and
even think about the concept and all
that
but i've always had this with my
companies which is like i need 15 i was
like at the very least this is just to
keep myself amused and engaged and like
a fan of my own business and because i
know if i'm like the mo if i'm just more
engaged in my own business i'm gonna do
that part will pay off and on the other
side it's like i think your consumers
the customers of your business also
pay attention
to that if they see you doing dope [__]
just for the sake of doing dope [__]
they kind of see you as the cool kid in
school in a way right like
if you're always just begging for for
customers or users or doing a discounted
sale or like saying please please please
follow me please please please subscribe
like you kind of are low status in a way
and i think at the hustle you guys did a
good job of this too did you do do you
have any examples of this yeah like we
did stuff early on that we kind of like
people got mad at and i was like they're
like you're gonna lose money lose
customers i'm like yeah but it's
hilarious like one time
uh we wrote entire
we wrote an entire email in trump's
voice and so we're like imagine like if
you read it and you were saying it out
loud like that it would sound like you
were donald trump
everybody loved it everybody's saying
it's the best people are saying that
they're saying it's the best
yeah like that's how that's that's like
how it was written uh and then another
time um
this was like pretty vulgar but it was
pretty funny we wrote the subject was
here's the only tip that you need to
know for how to be productive today at
work and you open it up and it was just
that picture of johnny cash where he
flicks off the camera and it just says
close this browser and get back to work
and now and like that was that was that
was it that was the email we sent that
to 120 000 people we didn't even like we
didn't even we didn't even send an email
and then maybe one final thing this
woman lindsay worked for me and she sent
the tuesday's email on wednesday which
is like a mistake and she's like [__]
she's freaking out and i was like here
do this um
i wrote in slack i was like hey
uh
you know i heard you sent the wrong
email and she replied in slack yeah my
bad i was really messed up i go
we gotta talk but until then just like
fix it and she replied with like what
should i do i was like i don't know man
just put the new email in and send it
again just take a screenshot of this and
like put that on and they'll understand
i'm sure and he goes and she replied
with something like funny and that was
just the screenshot that just went at
the top of the email there was no
explainer
right and so we would do like little
things like that all the time
what about you michael are there any
companies that you look at that uh kind
of fall into this category
it's super fun
uh well i did i did find one to talk
about the
have you guys done pop sockets before
you talk to that we haven't talked about
it now yeah it's a crazy story so um
it's the it's the little like you take
the the back of the case of your phone
and you put the little ring on it well
that's patented and they're called pop
sockets and they're very litigious so
the business started in 2014 and they
sold 30 000 of these things so they're
you know 10 or 12 bucks whatever um but
then they got really popular and people
the chinese started trying to knock them
off and sell them on amazon and all this
stuff um and so it was a uc boulder
professor and by 2017 they sold 35
million of them in 2018 they sold 60
million of these things so all because
they have a patent on this little way
that you know teenage young girls in
orange county want to grip their phone
like they're just printing money so
supposedly in 2018 they had 200 million
in revenue and 90 million in profit all
cause of a patent
it's one of the great one
one of the greatest
yes i know this is true because i got it
off of wikipedia when i researched this
a few months ago
yeah that's that's amazing got to be
several hundred million at least i mean
they got to keep growing
every lady i know has one of those
things fit your nails in there it's
great sam you want to know a little
realization i had today
when michael was coming on i was like
all right what do i know about michael i
was like he does that like chili's
little schtick where he's always like
you know
you know the only thing i don't even i
don't know how i would explain it but
basically you just find an excuse to
name drop chili's and say how great
chili's is and like why it's the best
place for a meeting and like you're just
like you know oh my god you know so
happy for you know mother's day i love
my mother but not as much as i love
chili's right like you just come up with
some way to like integrate chili's in
and so i don't know if you've seen this
but i i actually me and ben talked about
this once we go
when we were like trying to build up uh
my brand it was like all right i got
this podcast is brand new i got a
twitter it was like you know a few
thousand followers at the time it was
like what should we do to like
build a brand so we did this one like
you know two-hour exercise we just
looked at people who had good brands
we're like what are what are people
what's some common things that they do
and one of the things we found was that
a lot of people had early on in the tech
industry like uh or like sorry like
early on not early on the tech industry
that's like in the 70s or some [__] but
like early on when i got into tech i was
following some people on twitter and um
and i saw this guy ryan hoover and he
seemed like he was blogging he started
this thing called product hunt but ryan
would always
it was always phil's coffee and lacroix
like he would always talk about phil's
coffee and lacroix and in fact like
lacroix kind of became like a startup
meme i really give ryan a lot of credit
for it because he was always
talking about lacroix and then when
products got popular it just like
accelerated the like the lacroix meme in
the community as like you know what's
like loki great lacroix and like um
and so he had lacroix and then i don't
know so pop pomp does this thing with
dominoes all the time where he's like
he'll do like a domino's pizza he always
says that like domino's is the best i
think and um and he's just like and it's
kind of this thing where you get this
serious business persona in one way but
then you show this like human side and
it's like oh i'm just like i love this
thing you know i don't know if yours
would be like topo chico or something
like that like you used to like kind of
pip those out michael's got chili's we
got to make ours cheesecake factory yeah
like i was like chick-fil-a cheesecake
factory we need something that's like
our stick
that's like you can't just be false like
you got to genuinely have that love for
it the only part that's to stick is that
you talk about it and you don't really
talk about it's like you're serious
serious serious
topo chico because it's like you know
this makes the cut it's that important
to me
it's that good it is i'm that big of a
fan
you're like michael oh yeah we had a
great time you know what let me know
when you're when you're in austin we'll
go out some time for some cheesecake
factory and maybe get the chicken
piccata we'll have a great
time yes that's good is that a menu like
page 14 of the menu or 57 skinny-licious
menu
so i think i think when you pick this
thing the thing i would recommend it's
got to be something that's well okay so
here's the story for you so i'm 25 years
old and i'm finally figuring out how to
talk to women in my life like it's like
i had not figured it out at this point
and so my buddy and i decided to
start going to parties and we would
dress up in suits and this is like when
everybody's like dressed in like grunge
like in san francisco like so it didn't
work so we'd show up dressed in these
fancy suits and it was just odd enough
that the women would be like why are you
guys doing this like it's just it's just
slightly odd right and so i think you
need to figure talking
what's it called peacocking yeah okay
i could have been one of those like uh
with the pickup artist guys who who
needs to do this holdco stuff i could be
a pickup artist i have i could not do
that anyway uh i don't i don't like hair
gel enough but anyway the um
i think you got to figure out something
that's just a little bit odd you're like
why does this like technology
entrepreneur in san antonio like chili
so much so if the cheesecake factory is
that i think you're good but whatever it
is it's got to be just a little like
that they're like why are they why why
are they wearing suits to this party
like what's going on they can't be cool
yeah that's the first thing it can't be
cool because if you're just trying to
say something fad that like everybody
thinks is cool now you're just hopping
on a bandwagon you're actually you have
to say something that's actually not so
cool like for me like the genuine one
would be cinnabon like i [__] love
cinnabon nobody even thinks about
cinnabon so that's the corner for
cinnabon is open i can take that corner
you know that's a that's a piece on it's
a piece of land on the board that
nobody's touching right now i could just
pick that up for cheap
and but the people who but people do
know it it's kind of nostalgic and it
gives people something to like something
that they can gift you someplace they
can offer to take you
someplace that every time they go there
or see one they will think of you like
every time i drive by chili's god damn
it i think of michael gurdley right and
it's like same thing with lacroix and
ryan hoover it's like they own that
mental real estate in my mind
and so sam we could do that with
cheesecake factory we could just
every time someone sees it
they see us
you definitely should do that that's a
great idea
all right thanks for coming on man wait
wait he's got problems himself what's
on twitter
sick well thank you thank you for coming
on that was awesome
[Music]
you